the good thing is dude I I really do
feel like I'm like branching out and
doing things and like becoming a better
like a more well-rounded person I mean
dude I would have never thought ever in
my life I would go to Dave and Buster's
and not only that want to go but I did
my wife is like this person who God
bless her she's my angel and I love her
but she gets an idea and then wants to
do the idea immediately hey let's set up
a scavenger hunt tonight well that
requires so much to do okay then let's
fix up an old car with what Mizzou which
is her college team she's into sports
more than me which is not much they made
the playoffs or something right the top
16 or some which isn't it's like a
lot you know it's like basketball is the
only sport that'll be like
it's a dude they made the top 48 and
you're like what
call me when it's five
yeah dude and their team's never heard
of it's like yeah Fair found Fair
mountain walkerfield is dude the top
seed and you're like really what seed 29
and you're like that's bad
you look at the players are all like
tall white guys this is not they don't
deserve to be here
and so she's she's like oh great news
guess what and I and and she texts it to
me and I'm like oh I'm I'm uncanceled
and then she's like
and I go oh Mizzou made the top 16 right
64.
are you kidding me how many teams are
there yo here's the deal there should be
honestly
20 teams
60 they made the top 64. that was what
you wanted to she's over there watching
me right she's right here but so I'm
like but here's the deal so she's like
Mizzou made the top
64 which I didn't know so she says so I
get home I get home and she was like
I've got I've got it I've got the I've
got the idea
and I'm like what
and she says
Mizzou is playing tomorrow in California
Cal has never been a basketball game
it's my team
let's go now what did you notice in that
sentence
because I'll tell you where my man my
mind went right away
a dumb guy would be like
hell yeah
when do we have to leave I don't want to
catch traffic
but a smart guy dude is like
she said California
's big she made it seem like she tried
to sneak in like oh I would she tried to
play it like I was gonna think it was in
LA right
like you might as well have said like
North America you know like to get a
play on this planet
and so I'm like oh okay where and she
said you know it's our state we got to
go and I said yeah but where and she
says Sacramento and I go I'm too smart
for this game dude
no
pans down
right just
and and then what else do you want to
talk about
from now on that has nothing to do with
what we just stopped talking about
and she's like uh well come on it'll be
cows first we could go fly up tomorrow
stay in a nice hotel and I say there are
no high nice hotels in Sacramento
and I know that because I've been there
a bunch of times
and she's like well we could stay in San
Francisco and then drive and I'm like
dude this is an ordeal and also no hands
down
did we forget about that and she's like
but it's my team this has never happened
before and now just now I figure out
it's the top 64 teams
you know and uh and and so I'm just like
we're not doing it
so
we don't do it
and that's cool but then I'm like
wait a second the next morning I wake up
and I'm like dude
you can't even fly anymore she's a
hundred months pregnant
and she's like she and I didn't even
have to have the argument I became the
bad guy and now I gotta be like cater to
her her feelings because I said no when
in actuality I could have just like put
science on her and been like well you
know you can't fly she'll be like oh
yeah you're right I would have been good
guy
she tricked me dude women be tricking
dude
[Music]
you're crazy